good evening and welcome the subject of
this world leaders forum is of immense
importance to all of us gathered here
and also to many millions of Americans
who have been paying very close
attention to the presidential campaign
that has been closely fought and
continues to grow in intensity as
Election Day nears going back to FDR's
new deal brain trust and even before
Columbia has a history of world-renowned
economic scholarship combined with an
active engagement in advising government
leaders on critical questions affecting
the economy the distinguished scholars
we will be hearing from are without
question worthy representatives of this
proud tradition of public service
despite the differences in views of many
economists over many generations all
have shared the certain knowledge that
the field of economics and its relevance
to our country reach reaches far beyond
statistical measures of wealth and
poverty or forecasts of economic growth
and extend to fundamental questions
about what kind of society we choose to
live in as we've seen in the course of
this presidential campaign the choices
the president makes regarding economic
policy will affect many other critical
questions we face as a society not only
financial regulation or job creation but
the amount of authority delegated to
States the availability of affordable
health care the creation of sustainable
energy resources and the future of Big
Bird the ways in which the economy
affects these issues has been made
considerably more complex by the
extraordinary degree to which the United
States is now dependent on a global
economy nearly half of the revenue of
the SP 500 corporations comes from
business activity can
ducted outside this country and roughly
half of the manufactured goods purchased
by developed nations are produced in the
developing world it is undeniable that
the US workforce at all levels must be
trained differently if we are to thrive
in this new global economy yet it seems
in this campaign we have not had a
strong appetite for discussing this
challenge with the voting public to
tackle these important issues we are
fortunate to be joined by an outstanding
group of presenters and panelists and by
moderator Chrystia Freeland in the
spring of 2011 Chrystia became the
editor of Thomson Reuters digital a
highly respected journalistic voice on
the economy and our society she is the
author of a new book plutocrats the rise
of the new global super-rich and the
fall of everyone else which grew out of
an influential article of hers published
in the Atlantic in early 2011 before
Chrystia and our panelists take the
stage we will hear opening statements
from Glenn Hubbard Dean of the Columbia
Business School and Jeffrey Liebman the
malcolm weiner professor of public
policy at Harvard's Kennedy School Dean
Hubbard is the senior economic advisor
to the Republican presidential candidate
former Massachusetts governor Mitt
Romney professor Liebman serves in that
same capacity for President Barack Obama
enix in addition to their extensive
academic credentials each has spent a
good deal of time in washington d.c
serving in the executive branch dean
hubbard chaired the u.s. Council of
Economic Advisers from 2001 2003
advising president george w bush on
economic policy tax and budget policy
and international finance professor
Liebman was the acting deputy director
of the Office of Management and Budget
under President Obama and earlier was a
special assistant to president clinton
for economic policy focusing on social
secure
reform we will hear first from Dean
Hubbard and then from Professor liepman
please give them a warm welcome
we begin if I might just by thanking the
organizers for an event like this and
particularly to president Bollinger in
Columbia for emphasizing two things
first that ideas matter and second that
universities really are the right forum
for talking about those ideas this
November election is important from an
economic policy perspective it's the
most consequential in my lifetime that
observation is particularly true for
young people as there are competing
visions for our country's long-term
economic future I'll use my time to set
up the present economic situation
described the president's economic
policy failure and governor Romney's
policy alternative to begin with a
situation I think it doesn't shock
anyone and there's very little question
that the present situation is cause for
grave concern since the recession ended
GDP growth has been 2.4% in 2010
one-point-eight percent in 2011 and one
point seven percent so far in 2012 I'll
offer you a forecast but I'll remind you
that George Bush once said about me that
Glenn can't even predict the past and I
think what he meant by that had
something to do with data revision but
let me interject that humility I think
GDP will probably grow in the next year
in the one and a half for two percent
range we are stuck in a very bad
neighborhood the outlook for business
investment is particularly troubling is
this as good as it gets an environment
of less than two percent growth a
fraction of Americans unemployed or
involuntarily part-time we're giving up
on the job market of fourteen point
seven percent a collapse in the
employment population ratio real median
incomes down almost six percent since
the recovery began deficits have more
than a trillion dollars a year and
federal debt to GDP on a path to world
war two levels students in this audience
should pay particular attention to these
rising debt levels
using the forecasts of the Congressional
Budget Office with debt accumulated
under this administration and with the
president's proposals and no reforms the
International Monetary Fund estimates
costs of higher debt on future output to
reduce output by about seventeen percent
by 2050 that's a cumulative loss of 40
trillion dollars in present value left
unchecked that annual per family hit
would be about five percent of income by
2030 and more than a quarter by 2050
there's also a little question the
present situation is exceptional every
administration inheriting a recession in
modern times has done better the average
post-war recovery in GDP first 12 12
quarters after the end of a recession is
about fifteen percent recovery from the
very steep downturn in the 81 82
recession about nineteen percent over
that same period recovery from this
recession about seven measured on the
basis of jobs GDP growth and incomes
this is by far the weakest recovery of
the past ten recessions now to the
president's failure no reasonable
economist can suggest that all of these
problems are the president's fault but
there are significant questions about
his grasp of the problems his focus on
the economy and the extent to which he
missed opportunities for better policy
let me start with grasp the
administration both misjudged the
character of the downturn and
consistently forecast year after year a
sharp upturn in two years time except
the two years kept sliding much like a
hockey stick that just advances each
year with each passing week year the
misses in GDP and jobs forecasts exceed
those substantially of the bush and
Clinton administration's at the same
time the administration has adapted the
view of Carmen Reinhart and Ken Rogoff
that sluggish growth after a financial
crisis is
that's an interesting talking point
although as I just argued it would be
inconsistent with the administration's
own forecasts it is also inconsistent
with evidence as worked by Michael
Bordeaux and Joseph Holbrook shows
Milton Friedman's famous string plucking
analogy is still at Friedman famously
said that a business cycle understanding
is much like plucking a string the
harder you pluck the harder is the
opposing give translated into econ speak
a deep downturn should lead to a sharp
upturn historically deep recessions from
financial crises do actually recover at
faster cases and deep recessions without
them what ride art and Rogoff do by
contrast is focused on a different
metric of how long it takes to return to
the pre-crisis level of output now for
focus for the administration's first two
years it worked with a congress of its
own party yet the focus was not economic
recovery with a stimulus package that
was both poorly designed and poorly
matched the administration's own stated
narrative of the recovery the president
offered no plan to reduce federal
spending and stop the growth of the debt
to gdp ratio he failed to propose Social
Security and Medicare reform he favored
instead a large expansion of economic
regulation across many sectors with
little regard as the courts have
indicated for proper cost-benefit
analysis any disturbing degree of
favoritism toward special interests he's
missed opportunities that would link
short term fiscal action with long-term
reform his decisions have exacerbated
policy uncertainty with significant
costs in GDP and jobs a recent estimate
from economist University of Chicago and
Stanford suggests we lost about one
percent of GDP in 2011 on occasion of
this and returning to pre-crisis levels
of uncertainty would yield 2.3 million
jobs in 18 months on action the stimulus
has not been effective Fed Chairman
Bernanke has noted that fed policy
during the recovery
42 million jobs out of an anemic total
of about 5 million in the entire
recovery but even if all jobs were due
to the stimulus the cost would be a
hundred and fifty nine thousand dollars
per new private sector job or more than
a million dollars if one counts the debt
added over the period and to this one
can add industrial policy failures like
Solyndra in the fiscal policy program
the President's budget was rejected by
the Congress 414 20 in the house 99 20
in the Senate receiving no votes from
his own party tax increases on upper
income individuals and business owners
and on saving an investment that the
president has proposed would raise about
one percent of GDP but he proposes to
spend almost three percent of GDP higher
than the historical average with no
reform of entitlements the congressional
budget office estimates declining output
from President's budget outside the
budget window and Ernst & Young is
estimated seven hundred and ten thousand
jobs lost in the plan and taxes will
have to go up on all Americans to pay
for this it is simply mathematically
impossible to fund the spending levels
in the President's budget by raising
taxes on the well-to-do let me repeat
that it is mathematically impossible to
fund those spending levels simply by
raising taxes on the rich but putting
aside the green eyeshades the real
question from an economic perspective is
what economic model would suggest that
the president's proposals would raise
economic growth and reignite job
creation the president tells us we must
be patient and stay the course but we're
on the wrong course Governor Romney
offers a very different policy
alternative the Romney economic program
starts from a different place it
emphasizes that the present economic
situation reflects actually underlying
structural problems and a different
policy narrative is required what are
these structural problems they're an
uncompetitive tax code by global
standards an unsustainable fiscal policy
raising the prospect for households
businesspeople of large future tax
increases short shrift to free trade
poorly focused financial regulation poor
value in health care and an anti growth
regulatory climate a different policy
narrative the one Governor Romney
proposes would address these long-term
concerns improving constant confidence
shaping expectations reducing policy
uncertainty and creating room to move a
fiscal policy needed to do so in the
short run these ideas are based on
proven principles a more contained less
intrusive federal government a greater
reliance on the private sector a broad
expansion of opportunities without
government favors for special interests
and a respect for the rule of law
applying these principles governor
romney specifically would do the
following first reduce marginal tax
rates run business and wage incomes and
broaden the tax base to increase
investment jobs and living standards
he's proposing to cut the corporate tax
America's corporate tax being the
highest in the industrial world from
thirty five percent to twenty-five
percent increasing investment in profits
and also jobs and wages he would propose
to cut individual marginal tax rates the
tax rates paid by individuals in this
room across the board by twenty percent
providing especially large incentives
for investment in hiring by business
owners many business people pay taxes at
the individual rates he would broaden
the tax base in a progressive manner so
that upper income households bear a
disproportionately greater share of the
adjustment the intellectual forebears of
what I've just described include the
highly successful Tax Reform Act of 1986
President Bush's advisory commission
report of two thousand five in the
bowles-simpson plan of 2010 Governor
Romney would end the exploding federal
debt by controlling spending so that
spending doesn't exceed twenty percent
p a gradual fiscal consolidation toward
that level a level by the way that was
about the 40-year average before the
financial crisis he would improve social
security and medicare by reducing their
growth to sustainable levels insuring
their viability over time and protecting
those at or near retirement specifically
for social security gradually increasing
the retirement age and slowing the rate
of growth of benefits for affluent
people for Medicare shifting to a
premium support system with greater
support for lower-income Americans and
harnessing competition to lower costs he
would restructure financial regulation
the dodd-frank act calls to mind the
game show Jeopardy where one matches
questions and answers if dodd-frank is
the answer it's sometimes difficult for
me to think what the question might have
been the real questions facing the
financial services sector have to do
with the need to end too big to fail a
key problem not addressed substantially
in dodd-frank improving credibility
credit availability to entrepreneurs and
small businesses increasing regulatory
Accountability bringing private capital
back to Housing Finance which is now
dominated by the government and ensure
that regulations actually pass
cost-benefit analysis Governor Romney
would also promote energy policies that
increase domestic production encourage
the use of all Western Hemisphere
resources encourage the use of new
technologies and wasteful subsidies and
rely more on market forces and less on
government planning the bottom line here
is simple a change in policy is
essential if we are to raise growth and
incomes and reduce joblessness the
Romney economic plan delivers that
change in an economic assessment written
by Greg Mankiw John Taylor and myself we
estimate that if passed the Romney plan
would lead to near-term growth
acceleration into the three and a half
percent plus range and the creation of
12 million jobs over a president
Romney's
first term now let me close with the
following I know that hearing economists
like Jeff and me tonight you are
probably going to be reminded about
economics as a dismal science but I have
every reason to believe and I hope you
will be optimistic following what Lee
said about globalization as I look
around the world and I think of assets
and liabilities of different countries
and which mix what I want to be part of
what I want to own there's no question
in my mind that it's the United States
but no one in this room should take that
as manna from heaven again the
selections consequential my older son
recently turned 21 in my boring
economist way I wondered mathematically
of course what his prospects would be
when he gets to be my age with the
growth experienced over my lifetime he
and his friends will have incomes more
than double those of my cohort they can
use that buddy to fund Defense Education
a strong safety net a cleaner
environment and social justice but
growth is not a manna from heaven our
question is this can we pivot from this
administration's as good as it gets to
capturing and broadly sharing our
nation's opportunities yes we can thanks
okay thank you very much professor
Hubbard professor Liebman you couldn't
resist shaking your head a few times as
Professor Hubbard was speaking so have
at it great I think I'm gonna do my
opening remarks and then we'll go back
and forth a little bit of all Oh Glenn
doesn't have to worry quite yet the so
it's a pleasure to be here with you
today and it's a particular honor to be
standing here next to Glenn Glenn has
been a role model for me as a economics
professor who has managed to combine
influential teaching and research career
with multiple students in public service
and that said I'm going to do everything
I can do in the next 90 minutes to make
sure he doesn't have another one coming
in January as president Bollinger said
we're at a very consequential moment in
our country's history when the economic
choices we're about to make are really
going to matter we've been recovering
from the most serious economic downturn
since the Great Depression the economy
is moving forward again over the last 31
months the economy is added 5.1 million
private sector jobs manufacturing
employment is up 500,000 after declining
in every single year of the Bush
administration after years of not making
the investments that are necessary to
build a prosperous middle class our race
to the top program has fostered
innovation in our schools we're on a
path to double production of clean
energy and we're finally starting to
rebuild our nation's crumbling
infrastructure and after eight years
during the Bush administration that
turned record surpluses into record
deficits we're finally starting to
reduce our budget deficit again these
three issues what to do about the job
situation in the short term what to do
to create lasting economic growth and
economic growth that reaches the middle
class and not just the super wealthy and
how to bring down the budget deficit are
going to be the three most imp
portant tasks on the economics plate of
the next president and what we have
before us is two candidates who are very
different perspectives on how to get the
economy going governor romney wants to
go back to the trickle-down approach of
the last decade in which the theory was
that as long as you get government out
of the way and cut investments cut
regulations and cut taxes for the
wealthy everything else will take care
of itself President Obama believes that
the way to build a strong economy is
from the middle out and the 10 from the
bottom up he believes that there are no
shortcuts to build a prosperous middle
class that we have to make the
investments in education clean energy
innovation rd that will cause our
economy to grow let me say a little more
now about the president's approached on
each of these three issues jobs
long-term economic growth and the
deficit first on jobs it's certainly
taken a lot of hard work to get us back
to where we are today but there's still
a lot more work to be done the
centerpiece of the president's jobs
agenda is the American Jobs Act we would
put construction workers back to work
rebuilding our highways and our roads
and our runways it would give tax cuts
to small businesses that add jobs or
increase the wages of the current
employees it would prevent layoffs of
teachers and firefighters and it would
make it possible for responsible
homeowners to refinance their mortgages
at today's low rates these are standard
common sense approaches to the economic
situation we're in ones that have had
bipartisan support in the past
independent economists say that they
would add 1 million jobs to the economy
but Mitt Romney has opposed these
policies and Paul Ryan and his
colleagues in the house
block them Mitt Romney doesn't have a
policy to bring unemployment down in the
short term the only time he mentioned
jobs in the debate last Wednesday and
unfortunately the president stole my
joke was big birds and he wanted to get
rid of that one Mitt Romney is
enthusiastically endorsed the excessive
budget cuts of paul ryan's budget cuts
that under Romney's own numbers would
suck one percent of GDP out of the
economy in 2013 and experts have said it
would cost two million jobs next year so
if you're keeping score the president
has a policy that would add 1 million
jobs and Mitt Romney and Paul Ryan or
proposing policies that would cut 2
million jobs so they're three million
jobs hinging on who wins this election
let me now turn to the deficit how we
reduce the deficit is the most important
issue for our long-term economic growth
because getting the deficit down is
critical for not crowding out private
capital formation and getting it down in
a responsible way that allows us to
continue to make the investments that
are necessary for economy to grow it is
also crucial it's worth understanding
where these deficits came from 12 years
ago as president bush took office the
Congressional Budget Office was
projecting for 2001 a budget surplus of
two point six percent of GDP just two
years later that budget surplus had
turned into a deficit of three point
five percent of GDP so in two years
there was a deterioration of six percent
of GDP where did this come from well
President Bush pushed through two tax
cuts without paying for them in the post
9-11 era he raised spending on Homeland
Security and fought two wars again
without paying for them and he
introduced a new prescription drug
policy program for the elderly and again
didn't pay for them and the
Congressional Budget Office has shown
more than half of this deterioration in
our fiscal situation from the record
surpluses to the record deficits came
from those Bush policies the rest has
come from the aging of the population
the fact that we now have more seniors
receiving Social Security and Medicare
and from the financial crisis that we've
just been through the reason it's worth
reviewing this budget history is that
the policies that the Bush
administration followed and that
produced our deficits are exactly the
same policies the Mitt Romney and Paul
Ryan are proposing for America going
forward cut taxes for the wealthy
increase defense spending figure out how
to pay for it later we've seen this
movie before we know how it turns out it
results in massive budget deficits now I
want to say a few words about the five
trillion dollars in tax cuts the
Governor Romney has proposed since that
number got a lot of attention in last
Wednesday's debate five trillion dollars
is the gross cost of all the tax cuts
the Romney is proposed in which he's
been very specific about cutting
individual rates by twenty percent
abolishing the estate tax getting rid of
the alternative minimum tax cutting
corporate taxes so five million dollars
is the total cost of those taxes those
tax cuts if nothing else changes now
there are two things that the Romney
campaign's say that will change that
will mean that the net cost of this plan
will not be the full five trillion
dollars first they say that they're
going to get rid of lots of tax credits
tax deductions and tax exclusions in
order to offset the loss in revenue from
the tax cuts but the simple fact is that
even if you eliminate all one hundred
percent of the tax credits tax
deductions and tax exclusions that go to
the high-income taxpayers in this
country if you even if you eliminate all
of them you can't pay for the tax cuts
that Mitt Romney is proposing and so
that either means that he's going to be
raising the deficit or if he's going to
keep his plan revenue neutral he's going
to be passing along the cost to the
middle class now the Romney campaign has
been flail
around trying to prove that two minus
one equals 0 first they had Marty
Feldstein and Harvey Rosen two very
distinguished Republican tax economists
do studies to try to show that it was
mathematically possible to pay for the
five trillion dollar cost of Romney's
tax cuts but unfortunately for the
Romney campaign the proposals that came
up with first of all showed that you had
to raise taxes on the middle class and
second of all included getting rid of
the entire charitable contribution
deduction the entire home mortgage
deduction making all health insurance
premiums paid by employers taxable and
these are things that Romney said he
wouldn't do so then Romney himself said
well what he would do is he would cap he
would keep all the specific deductions
but he would cap the total deductions
that he wouldn't could take at seventeen
thousand dollars well it was quickly
pointed out that under this plan
millions of middle-class taxpayers would
see their taxes go up and on top of that
it would only pay for about a third of
the cost of his tax cuts so then the
Romney campaign said well but that
wasn't really his plan he was just
mentioning something that he'd heard
some members of Congress talk about so
where we stand today is that no one
affiliated with the Romney campaign and
no one else for that matter has been
able to write down any plausible tax
plan that could pay for the five
trillion dollar tax cuts that Romney has
proposed and indeed Romney himself has
been unwilling to name a single tax
loophole that he would close in order to
pay for this tax cuts because 2-1
doesn't equal zero the Romney campaign
is now turned to using quite exaggerated
assumptions about the growth
implications of their tax cuts there's
no justification either in economic
theory or in the empirical literature
for thinking that the Romney tax plan is
going to have a significant impact on
economic growth all of you who have
studied intermediate microeconomics know
that if you cut taxes on someone's
earnings but then offset the revenue
loss from that by raising taxes retail
sale
taxes on everything someone consumes you
haven't changed anybody's incentives
they have my earnings but they're paying
more for everything they consume and so
it's a wash and that's basically what
they're proposing they're cutting tax
rates and what people earn but they're
raising the taxes that people will be
paying on their mortgage interest
deduction on their charitable
contributions and other things that they
buy moreover because the Romney plan is
going to increase the budget deficit the
adverse effects of the budget numbers
that don't add up will offset any
positive gains from labor supply
incentives even if they were out there
now Glenn wrote a little report that he
referred to for the campaign in which he
cited lots of studies that supposedly
showed that a tax plan like Romney's
could lead to lots of increased economic
growth but any of you who are economics
majors I encourage you to go follow the
footnotes in that study and take a look
at the tax plans that he cites one of
them involves basically confiscating the
assets of the elderly in order to
produce economic growth another one gets
rid of all progressivity in the tax code
transferring massive amounts of income
from low income people to high-income
people a third one assumes that the Bush
tax cuts expire none of those plans have
anything to do with what Romney is
proposing but there's an even more
fundamental point beyond simply that
Romney's numbers don't add up and that
he's not being Frank with the American
people about the cost of his tax plan
but the bowles-simpson Commission showed
is that in order to bring down the
deficit we need to take a balanced
approach that combines both cuts in
spending and additional revenue the
president president's budget takes this
balanced approach seventy percent of its
deficit reduction comes from spending
cuts and thirty percent comes from new
revenue the president worked with
Congress last year to lock in 1.5
trillion dollars in discretionary
spending cuts over the next decade that
will bring domestic discretionary
spending to the lowest fraction of the
economy since the Eisenhower
administration and this was a deeper Cup
cut than even that called for in the
bowles-simpson plan the President's
budget matches the bowles-simpson plan
in its savings from Medicare and
Medicaid
and the President's budget winds down
the wars in Afghanistan and Iraq and
dedicates half the savings to deficit
reduction and the other half to making
investments here at home and finally the
president's plan raises additional
revenue by capping tax deductions for
high-income taxpayers and by returning
the marginal rates back to where they
were during the Clinton administration
by taking this balanced approach in
reducing the deficit with a combination
of spending cuts and new revenue the
president is able to bring the deficit
down to a sustainable level and he's
able to do that while maintaining the
critical investments in education
infrastructure rd that are critical to
our economic growth and prosperity going
forward Governor Romney has rejected the
balanced approach taken by Bowles and
Simpson he stood up there on stage with
the other Republican candidates during
the primaries and said that he wouldn't
accept a budget deal that had ten
dollars in spending cuts if it had one
dollar in new revenue and with no new
revenues and big increases in defense
spending and the repeal of the Medicare
savings that President Obama has
achieved the only way Governor Romney
can make his budget numbers add up is by
decimating this domestic discretionary
spending the category of spending that
includes veterans health care education
spending health research and many other
critical investments that our economy
needs now any time you mention a
specific one of these education
veteran's health transportation the
Romney campaign says no no no we
wouldn't cut that one but they haven't
told us what they will cut and
everything you take off the table means
the cuts to everything else will be even
deeper so when you look at all the
things that power our economy
investments in R&D education
infrastructure and reducing our deficit
to enable private sector capital
formation Governor Romney wants to
sacrifice all of them so they can give a
huge tax cut to those at the top and so
that he can buy a lot of weapons that
our military leaders say they don't need
I've said we've as I said before we've
run this experiment before and it failed
after the Bush tax cuts in 2001 job
growth coming out of that recession was
one
third as fast as it's been coming out of
the current recession so there's a lot
more ground to cover and i look forward
to covering it with you today the facts
here are important the specifics are
important and the president has shown to
fidelity to both but more important is
the vision the vision the president is
committed to is an economy that grows
from the middle out a sort of economic
growth that gives broad-based economic
prosperity thank
thank you very much professor Liebman
and thank you both for being such
excellent timekeepers I really
appreciate it now glennon jeff had a
last-minute idea on how to live in live
in the proceedings they each want 60
seconds to respond to one another's
presentations how about to message two
minutes ok you can have they can have
two minutes right they were good on the
time ok so you get two minutes to reply
to what the other guy said France or
Hubbard sure I just really wanted to
make three points first George Bush
isn't on the ballot Mitt Romney is on
the ballot Mitt Romney's plan is quite
specifically a broad-based tax reform
spending restraint both in the near term
and entitlements now the question of the
five trillion for those of you who are
washing and post readers or if you're
not feel free to turn to your electronic
device isn't about to say this Glenn
Kessler just this morning in the
Washington Post and his fact-check
debunked the president's continuing five
trillion dollar story the Romney plan is
a plan that is easily achievable with
feedback effects growth and base
broadening the paper by Harvey Rosen to
which jeff referred I would invite
anybody to go to the Princeton website
the context of the talk if you like and
have a look at the calculations
professor Rosen's in these sorts of tax
reform plans have been championed in
surveys written by Alan Krueger for
example was the chairman of the Council
of Economic Advisers by Alan Auerbach
from Berkeley another prominent
Democratic economists indeed I never
thought I would live to the day we're
finally a president proposes tax reform
only to see it criticized now as to this
notion of a balanced plan this is
another fact check moment for you if
you'd like to go into your Washington
Post archives because this four trillion
dollar balanced claim of the president's
is false and it's false in two respects
first of all it's not four trillion
dollars it includes about 1.6 trillion
dollars of things that were already
enacted and it includes funds for
stopping the wars which were already in
the baseline of about two trillion
dollars remaining 88
set or tax increases bowles-simpson is
balanced the president's plan is not but
let me close by asking the question I
asked during my remarks what economic
policies is the president suggesting
that would actually raise growth and job
creation we know the CBO says outside
the budget window output will be lower
as a result of the president's plan if
you do the boring little user cost math
for those of you republic finance
aficionados like me you'll find that the
president's tax increases on small
business alone more than Trump the tax
benefits that he's giving the plan
simply doesn't add up ok thank you very
much Glenn please I think there are
seven whoppers here I need to correct
first of all on the four trillion in
deficit reduction I find it remarkable
that the president is being criticized
for the fact he's already accomplished
1.5 trillion of that indeed that's more
than half of the deficit reduction on
the spending side that was called for by
simpson-bowles so the point here is that
the president's already made progress on
this it's not just a promise going
forward on the war spending the baseline
has assumes that we're going to keep
spending money in the long run on these
activities in Afghanistan the president
plans to bring that those down Mitt
Romney criticized the president for
ending the war in Iraq and has
criticized the president for saying he's
going to bring our troops home from
Afghanistan so having the president take
credit for something he said he's going
to do and Romney said he isn't going to
do seems quite legitimate now in his
opening remarks Glenn had to work really
hard to try to paint a dark picture
about the economic recovery first of all
he said that the economy is growing
slower now than it was a year ago that's
simply not the case the economy has
created 151,000 jobs on average during
the last 12 months they created a
hundred and fifty one thousand jobs on
average in the previous 12 months in the
last 12 months the economy has grown to
the 2.2% rate in the four months before
that it grew at a 1.9 percent rate and
both of those were fast to the
the one point eight percent rate of
growth that we had in the bush
administration coming out of the 2001
recession perhaps the biggest whopper
Glenn told was complaining about the
employment to population ratio coming
down so here's what's going on the baby
boomers are retired of retiring so if
you take the more people who are over 65
and who aren't working anymore and so
naturally the share of the adult
population that's working is going to go
down and there's actually a study from
2002 back when Glenn was chairman of the
Council of Economic Advisers put out by
the government in that year that
forecast that over the time period where
in the employment the labor force
participation rate would fall from 67 to
sixty-three percent as the baby boomers
retired now if you do this number
properly and you age adjust the
employment to population ratio what you
see is the employment the population has
gone up by a full percentage point in
the last year okay I'm going to have to
stop you there Jeff I gave you an extra
25 seconds as I gave Glenn to okay I was
just gonna ask you for the 25 okay thank
you both very much okay I was on one of
those unwatched cable news shows last
week and one of my fellow media
bloviator said you know the problem with
the debate is you have ill-informed
journalists moderating and what you
should instead have is a panel of
brilliant and experts ask questions of
the candidates so Columbia has hit upon
the ideal format for this sort of
interrogation and it is easy president
Bollinger for you to do because you have
such an excellent faculty so i will
quickly introduce the faculty panelists
and then their job is to grill the
economic advisors sitting next to me is
of course Joe Stiglitz my friend
Pulitzer prize-winner university
professor a general genius in many
different fields and I can't resist I've
known Joe for a long time next to Joe is
Sharon O'Halloran she is the george
blumenthal professor of political
science international
look affairs she described herself to me
as perhaps the token political scientist
on the panel I think she is a good deal
more than that and I very much look
forward to her questions and next to her
is michael woodford he is the John Bates
Clark professor of political economy and
his particular expertise is in
macroeconomics and monetary policy some
areas that have a little bit of heat and
action in them right now so I look
forward to your questions too we're
going to allow them to fire off their
questions in alphabetical order so I'm
going to turn to you first to Professor
o halloran go for it that's good 10
comes first so let's talk about specific
plans and comparisons and at the end of
this year the u.s. is set to fall off
the fiscal cliff and it matters because
they're going to be many constraints and
we're worried about going back into
recession that is there's going to be
automatic tax increases and spending
cuts will click in you'll mention them
and among the laws set to change include
the end of last year's temporary payroll
tax cuts right which will increase taxes
on on workers for about two percent the
end of certain tax breaks for businesses
ships in the alternative minimum tax
they'll take a large a bite out of
middle-class incomes the end of the Bush
tax cuts beginning of taxes related to
President Obama's health care law's and
at the same time you have the spending
cuts agreed to upon as part of the debt
ceiling of deal of 2011 are those cuts
are going to start taking effect so what
I want is you describe a spending and
tax plan that will help us avoid the
fiscal cliff and state why your
candidate is the best one to enact this
deal ok let's go in opposite order Jeff
you go first and can you do it in two
minutes again I'll do my best although a
full tax and budget plan probably hard
to do in two minutes but I'll do my best
the first thing is we have to avoid the
cuts from the fiscal cliff they're not
meant to be enacted they're meant to be
so terrible that little force other
action and so the President believes
the number one thing we have to do is
right after the election finally sit
down not pass the buck any further and
do the bipartisan budget deal that needs
to happen and the only thing that's
standing between us and getting that
budget deal done is the Republican
refusal to accept even one dollar in new
revenue as part of the budget deal you
know with the baby boomers retiring
spending on social security medicare and
medicaid is going to go up by 3
percentage points of gdp over this
decade that's not because anybody's
passing any new laws it's just because
the population is aging and so to think
that we can live with historic levels of
revenue given that we suddenly have to
meet our commitments to our seniors
doesn't make any sense and more broadly
given that a lot of the spending cuts
we're going to do are going to be
broadly felt it makes sense to have tax
policies that ask high-income people to
pay their fair share as well so the
number one thing the president thinks we
need to do is is do they do the big
budget deal the second thing that the
President believes is that we should
have an agreement to not use routine
expiration of debt limits as an excuse
for hostage taking and leading the
country to the verge of financial crises
and what would help right now is that
both sides of the aisle would agree that
we're not going to do that kind of thing
i bet i'm up in laughs yeah cool okay
keep going so you know the third thing
the President believes is that as part
of this deal we have to do something
about the immediate job situation I
described the American Jobs Act for you
and something i want to emphasize is
that what Romney and Ryan are proposing
in their budgets that the House
Republican budget that Romney has
enthusiastically endorsed the budget
cuts in that budget for 2013 are fifty
percent larger than the budget cuts in
the sequester so when people say that
the sequester is going to cost two
million jobs if it happens if that those
numbers are right it means the
romney-ryan budget is going to cost
three million jobs ok that's a good
moment for you to start I'm an editor I
I'm qualified to make that point Glenn
go for it 33 points
first the president was very worried in
2010 about expiring tax cuts on upper
income Americans because of worries
about economic growth why not now we're
not doing better point2 on the spending
and tax plan the fiscal cliff this is
really a political scenario and I'm not
political scientist but I'll game out as
best I can a scenario under which Mitt
Romney as president is probably a
scenario under which the Congress is
also his own party and it's a fairly
straightforward description given the
way resolution packages work Romney
would introduce his own plan which would
gradually reduce spending relative to
GDP to twenty percent tax reform and a
healthier economy produces a system that
raises between eighteen and nineteen
percent of GDP in revenue it would be
very important to also start entitlement
reform the simplest to begin to give the
public confidence would be to block
grant the Medicaid program which
governor Romney's proposed one order up
in difficulties so probably not right
away is the Social Security reform I
mentioned and too hard for year one
would be would be Medicare if the
president is reelected with a congress
not entirely of his own party which
would be the other likely scenario I do
think we have a risk of actually going
off the fiscal cliff both sides seem to
believe they have the upper hand in the
negotiation and again I'm not a
political scientist but I want to end on
one thing that I agree with Jeff a
hundred percent and this is on the
politics of the debt limit we have got
to get to a point in the country where
we understand that spending and taxes or
fundamental decisions whether we pay our
bills is not okay Romney only makes it
if it's unified government and a
partisan bill and Obama does on
bipartisan no I'm saying Obama won't
accomplish it at all that's what i mean
by going off the cliff if Governor
Romney is elected he would have the
ability to pass his own plan the
President did do 1.5 trillion dollars in
deficit reduction last year working with
Congress okay Joe
k 1 remarks that was made a present
Bollinger in beginning would refer to
how we measure success of our economy
and before even before the crisis the
Bush policies brought on median income
in United States was actually lower than
had been almost a decade earlier so I'm
going to ask I guess both Canada both
both both the other speakers what
specifically would they do to help the
middle and the bottom in particular do
they believe in trickle-down economics
and would a tax cut for or extending the
Bush tax cuts for the millionaires do
they believe that that would help the
middle class and do they believe that
are contrary do they think that
repealing ending the tax cut for the
millionaires and ending the special
treatment of taxes of speculators that
they are taxed at a fraction of ordinary
workers do they believe that that helps
the American economy okay Joe you've
left us in grave doubt as to how you
would answer that question yourself so
um Glenn please yeah I can it's too
subtle Joe I'll have to figure out what
you want you mean first of all Joe is
asking essentially important question
task of economics is not simply to
deliver a higher level of growth but a
distribution of those benefits that's
broad and widely shared I might suggest
it for this administration or a couple
of problems something mortgage
refinancing came up that is the plan I
have some passing familiar with since it
is my own the administration has
systematically frustrated its
implementation to the benefit of banks
against homeowners and has endorsed a
financial reform that codifies too big
to fail so it's an odd populism do your
point about the middle class I would
make three suggestions one at the risk
of sounding like President Kennedy
growth is the key first step the second
is may sound unusual to many in the
audience but it's about getting health
care costs down it's not so much that
compensation is measured by business
people is not keeping up with
productivity its wages that are not
keeping up with productivity and part of
that has to do with very excessive
health care costs market-oriented health
care reforms can reduce the level of
those costs and importantly improve the
distribution of income and the third is
about education and training the two
candidates didn't come up in our remarks
but the two candidates have very
different views here Governor Romney is
trying to encourage much more
competition in primary and secondary
education and a radical rethink of
training taking what we currently do in
the Department of Labor and repurposing
it to block grants to States and to aids
directly to individuals for any
presidential candidate particularly
Republican presidential candidate that's
that's pretty radical rethink those
would be my three points okay that was
exactly two minutes please thank you I
hope we can come back to the housing and
the financial regulation issue later in
this discussion but I'm going to stick
to the middle class question for the for
the moment what shows that is exactly
right middle class incomes have been
falling for more than a decade now even
in the last administration when the
economy was expanding middle class
incomes were falling and although
they've median incomes with risen by
about a thousand dollars in the last 12
months we got a lot of hard work left to
do to build an economy where the
prosperity is shared broadly and not
just according to the top the president
during the last few years was sensitive
to what the middle class was going
through he provided the average middle
class family with thirty six hundred
dollars of tax relief but that's a
short-term solution what we need is a
lasting solution that increases
middle-class wages the president in his
goals for the next term has focused on
that question first on education policy
which he thinks is the most important
way to build a prosperous middle class
he wants to build on when he's already
done
so what he's done so far is on k-12
education he's had what's called the
race to the top which gave incentives
for states to figure out ways to raise
standards and come up with innovative
solutions to education and all the
governors in the country you almost got
together with with innovative plans to
compete for these grants and and we're
seeing the fruit of that innovation in
our schools today the second thing the
president did already is to make college
more affordable he got rid of the excess
of fees going to banks that were
financing financial aid and used that
money to expand Pell grants he created
the american opportunity tax credit
which gives ten thousand dollars in tax
breaks to people who are in college for
four years and he's greatly expanded
support for community colleges if they
worked with businesses so that the
training they're giving leads directly
to a job okay all right well tell you
about the future next time I talk it
tells about the future next time okay
when we look forward to that one
professor Woodford so I think both of
our speakers have just indicated some
interest in talking more about about
mortgage reforms so I thought I bring
that out but many analysts would argue I
think that one of the main factors still
holding back the US economy at present
is the high level of mortgage debt that
a lot of households are caring many
households have found themselves in
greater trouble paying their mortgage
debt than they would have anticipated
maybe because of losing jobs and finding
it hard to find new jobs in the current
labor market or in some cases having
been counting on refinancing their
mortgages and finding that unexpectedly
much more difficult than and they would
have expected because of changes in the
value of the collateral that they have
and unexpected changes in the mortgage
underwriting standards by lenders at the
same time I think it's true that the
degree of mortgage relief provided thus
far has been fairly modest and the main
program that's been instituted by the
administration the Home Affordable
Refinance Program has refinance less
than I think a million mortgages which
is a lot less than the three to four
million that had been the announced goal
of the program and I think even a
smaller fraction of the number of
borrowers who are probably at risk of
being unable to pay mortgages and so I
guess the question I'd like to address
to both of you is whether the next
administration should be doing more and
in what way something different than
what we've already done of this problem
okay Jeff I think you should start great
what have you done wrong so funny so
there are two problems that need to be
solved in terms of helping families with
their mortgages the first is that there
are families who can't afford to pay
their mortgages given the terms of their
current mortgage and for closing is not
a good solution because it imposed a lot
of costs on the families and a lot of
costs on the banks as well and in most
cases if you can restructure the
mortgage you can end up letting the
family stay in its home and it's a
better outcome both for the lenders and
for the family so the first challenge is
how do you do that the second challenge
is we have millions of homeowners who
are paying their mortgages on time all
the time regularly but who have interest
rates still at six or seven or eight
percent and would like to refinance
today's current rates but they're not
able to because the banks aren't
offering them the opportunity to do that
so the president has aggressively worked
on both of these problems and I think
Mike's numbers on the impact of the
president's policies grossly under state
the impact they've had because the
policies have worked not directly not
only by having the government explicitly
offer refinancing or subsidized work
outs of mortgages that are in distress
that they've also worked by creating
templates that the private sector has
followed to do these things directly
without needing
women to help so if you look at the
overall numbers that they're about 50
million homeowners in America about 18
million have been able to refinance
using some combination of methods that
are in some way tributyltin to
government policy and the president's
policies have avoided 1.4 million
foreclosures so the president been
working hard on this he has legislation
before Congress right now the boxster
Menendez bill that was developed by two
really smart people who happen to be
professors here at Columbia including
Glenn Hubbard and unfortunately I'm
throughout the sizing housing crisis
Mitt Romney has been a wrong side he
said we should simply let the market
work itself out hit bottom estimates say
that that would have caused seven or
eight percent decline in in in mortgage
in housing prices and so there's a big
difference between the president who was
acted aggressively and Mitt Romney who
said let the housing market hit bottom
okay Glenn a couple of points first of
all whenever you hear barbara boxer's
name and mine in the same sentence you
should be suspicious and I won't
necessarily go to all the details here
but I will talk about the economics of
Mike's question there's a real problem
with the lack of mortgage refinancing a
couple of reasons one Mike alluded to
which is a sharp decline in household
net worth which frustrates consumption
in the recovery he also is a blocked
Channel for monetary policy you know the
Federal Reserve has been very aggressive
and appropriately so particularly the
early stage of the crisis yet the very
low interest rates didn't have the
traditional effect they might have
through mortgage refinancing this is
because as Jeff said we'd had negative
equity positions for many households in
2008 Chris mayor and I had suggested
that the government needed to do two
things one was to have a look back at
the 1930s homeowners loan corporation
but the second was to use the
government-sponsored enterprise I would
not have done but then secretary of the
Treasury Paulson did do since the
taxpayer is already own
the risks of the mortgages are already
on our collective books let's refinance
mechanically that is like a long-term
tax cut those interest rates of seven
these Jeff's example become more like
for what has happened on the president's
watching on his Treasury Secretary's
watch the GSEs have frustrated this
through fees through poor implementation
and eventually all people watching this
view this as an episode of how not to
make a program to work what Governor
Romney has said is that these programs
he's happy to see work as effectively as
they could but we shouldn't be confused
that our long-term goal still has to be
to return the private sector back to the
housing work okay thank you very much
now we are supposed to shortly take
questions from the audience but we
started a little bit late and I haven't
heard enough brilliant cross-examination
from your brilliant faculty here so I'm
going to suggest that each one of you
asked one more question and my request
is if you could make the question very
very succinct and maybe only get 60 you
get one minute each to reply okay okay
so will reintroduce the financial
regulation question of one of those
signature pieces of the legislation
during the Obama administration has been
dodd-frank regulatory reforms and yet
since the passage less than thirty
percent of the rules that the law
mandated have been promulgated and many
that have been written are seen as
either too complex are completely
unworkable so state how your candidate
would seek to remedy the shortfalls
shortfall of dodd-frank to best ensure
efficient regulation of financial
markets okay Glenn well fix dodd-frank
in 60 seconds okay I'll do my best first
of all you noted correctly Sharon
dodd-frank has generated enormous number
of policy uncertainty contributions you
heard in the debate the other night the
debate over qualifying mortgages which
is stymied the banking industry and and
lending a central issue for me and
dodd-frank as i said is its failure to
address too big to fail doubles down by
naming names naming systemically
important institutions naming
institutions that have a direct line to
the taxpayer we will
avoid the next financial crisis that way
the way it sets up the financial
stability Oversight Committee so-called
F sock almost increases the likelihood
of a crisis by giving that committee the
ability to rearrange claims heading to
bankruptcy the legislation also has no
regulatory Accountability the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau comes to
mind what would Governor Romney do end
too big to fail we need to move to a
regime with an alternative bankruptcy
regime or a bail-in and we need to
replace the CFPB structure with one that
has a board and isn't simply sucking
money out of the federal reserve but has
to go to the Congress just like everyone
else okay Jeff now you fix it or maybe
you think it's perfect already yep let
me describe what dodd-frank does first
it imposes new capital standards so that
next time thanks do risk investment it
doesn't become all of our problem the
second thing it does is it prohibits
banks from doing proprietary trading and
taking risks that then spill over to
other depositors third it brings
derivatives the derivative market out of
the shadows and makes their be
transparency in what kind of products
are out there fourth it creates a plan
for the big banks for what they're going
to do if they get in the financial
trouble and it creates the authority for
the regulators to step in and take steps
so that if those bakes get in trouble we
don't end up destroying the whole
financial system but we have an orderly
way to unwind things fifth it exempts
small banks from the new standards and
the new regulations and six that gives
consumers protection against deceptive
regulatory practices all of these things
seem to me to be responsible reactions
to the the crisis we've been in it's
clear that when you have a regulatory
process to fill in the details of a
piece of legislation you want to do that
in a careful way so that you can get
feedback from everyone who's involved
and so the sooner we get all the details
settle the way the better but the idea
that we should yield that dodd-frank and
go back to the old system is not the
solution okay thank you very much now
actually I would love to hear what
thinks about how to fix dodd-frank but
this is not the place to hear that so
your question please okay I want to go
back to the question of the tax coxon
and assessing their distribution and
fiscal affects the first is three
aspects of the first is that we know
back in the reagan tax cuts there was a
lot of dynamic scoring the statement is
that they would pay for themselves and
from what I heard and Bush had similar
kind of thing and didn't happen why do
you think the feedback mechanisms and
this growth is going to be enabled the
the tax cuts not to have the adverse
effects that everybody else thinks
secondly that's two grand right one
that's to Glen to Glen or do both of
them you ask me this every day so that's
our second the second is that an aspect
of cutting out the deductions which in
the long run most economists think would
be a good thing is that the home
deduction would be cut out and given the
weakness in the real estate market that
has already been alluded to wouldn't
that make things worse and the third
point is we've been talking about
arithmatic possibilities is it seems to
me every study I've seen suggests that
it's impossible to lower tax rates
across the board by twenty percent
without decreasing progressivity even if
you eliminated all tax deductions for
the top okay that sounded to me like a
question that really is only for Glenn
so Glenn go ahead and answer you Jeff
watch Jeff okay okay but Glenn you get
to go first sure it's a great question
and it's an important one governor
Romney's tax reform plan is a central
reason to think about him as a candidate
so it's very important tax cuts don't
pay for themselves people like me have
told this to conservative politicians
for as long as I've been in this
business but they do generate two kinds
of feedback and again I'd come in for
students in the audience particularly
Harvey Rosen's paper on his Princeton
website the first kind of feedback you
could think of as micro feedback how
households arranged their affairs in
response to the tax system an economists
estimate this is large literature on
this what Professor Rosen does is take
half of the standard value so very
conservative the second kind of effect
is if a tax reform raises growth which
is by the way the reason to do it in the
first place the cornerstone of studies
going back to Larry Summers work in the
early 1980s what Professor Rosen does is
take the lower bound of those estimates
if you do that it is quite easy to
accomplish what Governor Romney is
saying just have a revenue neutral tax
plan that you should know is easy
bowles-simpson actually raised two
percentage points of gdp with the same
marginal race you know that part's easy
and distribution Aleut reality from the
fact that you have growth and the
feedback effects as to your point about
the deduction for home mortgage interest
Governor Romney is said look everything
is on the table and we have to be
progressive a couple of road maps for
that one would be look at bowles-simpson
and in bowl Simpson as you know the home
mortgage interest deduction was treated
in a way that for most middle-income
people it's about the same as they
experience now the changes would be for
upper-income people alternatively you
could take a deduction cap relative to
adjusted gross income which Marty
Feldstein and Miami Guinness to propose
you could do a lot of these things but
it is definitely and trivially easily
shown to be mathematically impossible
again I commend the rosin paper but if
it's not enough the Tax Foundation Alex
Brill Matt Jensen and many others things
okay Jeff this is a real softball for
you but please then referred to the
simpson-bowles plan and I think that's
illustrative for understanding the
challenge we face in getting the budget
deficit down so simpson-bowles raises
revenue a relative to the baseline by a
couple of percent of GDP and it does it
by closing tax loopholes expanding the
tax base and the President's budget does
that as well given the seriousness of
our deficit problem we need to be doing
this we need to be expanding the tax
base and using that to bring down the
death
now simpson-bowles does also bring down
marginal rates but it pays for that by
taking the tax rate on capital gains and
on dividends back to the ordinary level
Romney has ruled that out the reason
this matters is that the reason that the
simpson-bowles plan is able to do tax
reform and do it in a way that doesn't
Kluber the middle class is that by going
after the tax expenditures for dividends
and for capital gains they're going
after a form of tax expenditure that
particularly benefits high-income people
and Romney by ruling out going after
those preferential tax rates can't
design a plan that doesn't give massive
tax increases to the rich okay Mike the
the Federal Reserve has been the subject
of unusual controversy over the last few
years for example the Republican
platform adopted this summer calls for
an annual audit of the Federal Reserve's
activities at the same time some
Democrats in Congress have called for
stripping the regional Federal Reserve
Bank presidents of their voting rights
on the Federal Open Market Committee of
presumably out of displeasure with the
way they've been voting so the question
I'd like to pose to both of you is
whether the next administration should
be trying to achieve fundamental changes
in the direction of Fed policy either
through these kinds of institutional
reforms or perhaps just by appointing a
different type of people to the key
positions okay Jeff please thanks Mike
that's that's an excellent question what
economic research has shown I think
quite conclusively is the countries that
have independent central banks have much
better economic growth in much lower
inflation that country than countries
where the federal that the central bank
is politicized and so there's a
tradition both the people serving in the
administration and the executive branch
and also people serving as campaign
advisors of not commenting on Federal
Reserve policy in order not to threaten
that independence but i will say that i
don't think the activity going on in
Congress either this what you've
described or the efforts by paul ryan
and his republican colleagues to
intimidate the fed I don't think those
are helpful given the importance of
independence
of the fed to the economy of the u.s.
okay preferred I was really hoping you
would ask that question and particularly
looking forward to Glenn's reply well I
would it's a great question Mike and I
would have been surprised if evening and
gone by without hearing it from you I I
would give it to part answer what about
policy and the other about process and
on policy I think there are reasons to
disagree I would be personally critical
of the efficacy of qe3 for example but I
would be perfectly supportive of the
feds desire to do so the Fed believes it
can do so it's an independent central
bank at you do I personally as
economists don't think it's an
outstanding policy I think the Fed is
trying to repair damage that fiscal
policy needs to do your mortgage
refinancing question was only one
example of that but the broken fiscal
policy and structural problems are not
something that monetary policy can fix
on process my mind the Fed should focus
mainly on price stability and financial
stability and the Fed has wound up
politicizing itself a bit and I don't
mean that as a criticism because it was
actually a necessary consequence of
going through the financial crisis and
taking on a lot of turf in financial
regulation which definitely draws the
Congress's attention I hope and I agree
with Jeff very much on this that whoever
is elected president we see a cooling
down of discussions about the Federal
Reserve is very important for the
Federal Reserve to conduct monetary
policy but it will be important for the
next president to make the policy
appointments that he sees is consistent
with his economic views okay thanks a
lot now we're going to turn to some
questions from the floor and I have to
say these are all really excellent I
wish it were possible to petition for an
extra half hour so so you guys could
answer all of them the first one is from
Andrea he's at Barnard College and she
asks how if at all does your candidate
plan to give Americans economic
incentives to combat climate change when
you're at first
I think the key issue in combating
climate change is to think about the
energy mix that we use in the country
that it is largely a technology solution
at the present time we have a number of
regulatory barriers to the adoption of
cleaner technologies particularly in the
use of natural gas and I think this is
something that the next administration
whether it's a real ected President
Obama or Governor Romney have to focus
on the same time we should really
increase substantially our support for
basic research in this area and our
willingness as a country to have the
kind of serious international
negotiations we need with large emitting
countries the u.s. is no longer the top
of that list so those would be my
approach the technology the research and
negotiation well in the long run what we
clearly need is a international
agreement that uses market incentives to
reduce emissions in the most efficient
way as possible but in the current
economic climate that's not probably
going to happen anytime soon it's very
hard to do things that put a price on
carbon when people are worrying about
their short-term economic situation and
so the over the next few years the key
thing is to keep making the kinds of
investments in clean energy that we've
been making in this administration we're
on a path to double production of clean
energy during the president's first term
and clean energy doesn't just mean solar
and wind it means clean coal it means
pushing forward on natural gas it means
that the president has has has started
us on the path toward the first new
nuclear power plant in a long time and
we really need to use it on all of the
above strategy but there's a big
difference here between the two
candidates mitt romney wants to continue
giving subsidies to the oil companies
barack obama wants to use those
subsidies instead to invest in clean
energy okay next question uh this is
from jennifer ham who is in general
studies
and she asked it's clear that China has
been undervalued currency for some time
how do you plan on dealing with that
Jeff great that's a that's a great
question and in fact my the only time I
got to travel during my two years in
government was a 16 hour trip I was only
grounded for only 16 hours in Beijing to
talk to the Chinese about this issue the
president has been very vocal in this
issue both in public and in private
saying that the Chinese need to
appreciate that their currency they did
remove the peg to the dollar and that's
allowed their currency to appreciate by
ten percent but that's not enough and
and and and we keep to need to keep the
pressure on them to do more and we also
have to keep fighting hard to make sure
that China plays by the the trade rules
this president has brought twice as many
trade cases to the WTO about violations
by China as as President Bush did in the
equal amount of time and and and you
will continue to stand by our workers
and our firms going forward okay when I
would say three things of the first
order issue I think between the United
States and China in trade is trade rules
and intellectual property which i think
is what Jeff was referring to and when I
speak to Chinese leaders about this I
remind them that this is not about their
duty to us that's not every meaningful
statements about their duty to
themselves and by this I mean that in
the current five-year plan for China
there's a big emphasis on
entrepreneurship you will not have a
vibrant climate for entrepreneurship if
you don't respect property rights in
your country so this is something I
think Chinese leaders will come to
naught again as a bone for the United
States because it's in their own
interest the second has to do with the
financial system China has a financial
system that is simply not adequate for
its growth aspirations as a country and
it is in need of radical reform and this
is I would submit to you the issue in
which the US needs to have most
discussions on the issue of the currents
that is a vehicle through us procedures
and laws to have these more vigorous
discussions but I don't think that's the
number one is
between the US and China okay I note
with interest a bit of editorializing
here that Jeff sounded more hawkish on
China than Glenn which is not what I
would have expected had their two
candidates been here okay last question
and you will understand why I chose this
one it's from sameep achetez she's a
machete is a journalism student and the
question is with corporate taxes as a
percentage of GDP falling how does
romney's plan address the problem of
corporate rates not paying as much as
they should Reuters research shows 19
out of 30 doubt companies pay a maximum
rate of only twenty-eight percent two or
three got a tax game so you're at first
one sure it's a great question I
mentioned in my remarks that the u.s. is
uncompetitive in the corporate taxes
highest corporate tax rate in the
industrial world many continental
European countries that one might think
of as being not as friendly toward
business as in a typical American
administration actually have lower
corporate tax rates and they do this
because they realize that in order to
have an efficient business sector when
capital is mobile low corporate tax
rates are the norm producing higher
revenues in the country and relying on
other taxes to fund to fund government
services the US could profitably reduce
corporate taxes from 35 well into the
20s without losing much revenue that's
not magic or an argument about tax cuts
paying for themselves but an argument
about two simple things one the
investment that companies would then do
in the United States as opposed to
overseas and second the ability to
locate more profits back here in the
United States so the US tax authority
would take credit for them yes well I
think we finally have an issue in which
we agree the the president has proposed
reducing corporate tax rates to a number
in the 20s and unlike Governor Romney
the president has also been very
specific about which tax preferences for
corporations he would close to pay for
it so I I think I agree with that
everything Glenn just said on that that
the candidates do I think have a
fundamental difference in
national taxation of corporations
however the President believes that we
have to crack down on the incentives
that firms have to move jobs overseas
and he believes that if companies
operate in tax havens they should be
have to be taxed immediately on the
income that they earn Romney wants to
move to a territorial system that would
eliminate all taxation if an American
company moved its operations overseas
okay our time it has just about run out
and before we have final statements from
each of the speakers I just wanted to
hear one last word from our brilliant
faculty panelists I didn't warn them
about this so and so you guys each face
a blitz question if you dare you may say
who you think won this debate and if you
want to weasel out you can say what was
the most surprising thing that you heard
when you start with Professor Woodford
I'm not I'm not Benedict Larabee Claire
who won the debate I mean yes I'm still
puzzled by how difficult it is to really
get to the bottom of the questions of
whether the whether the tax and budget
numbers add up or not at all I'll say we
you know we put several things on the
table and I feel like I feel we haven't
really done gotten to the bottom me
obviously I'll go for a tie and I'll
thank them both but I mean in the end it
really when you think about what's going
on that the question is what gives you
the highest return to productivity and
growth and we know that's the investment
in human capital and what I don't hear
is its vision on how you're going to
have a human capital plan not just a
physical capital investment that leads
to long-term productivity and long-term
growth yeah and and i actually had
somewhat the same concerns that you know
we're facing a set of dilemmas talked
about a number then one of them is how
do we protect seniors and the candidates
seem to be committed to protecting
seniors and invest in the future and
invest in the future we're really
talking about young people human capital
on the positive side we've heard
something about something that's been
done about student loans and the
exploitation by the financial sector oh
you know the bankruptcy law that was
passed under under President Bush that
makes it more difficult to discharge
student loans and I guess I I haven't
yet heard a clear vision of how we're
going to promote these investments in
our future okay a president Bollinger I
had no idea your faculty were such easy
graders I expected a little more
aggression there okay you now have a
chance to answer some of these questions
i'm going to give you two minutes each
and let's go in the opposite order of
the opening
remarks okay that means I get to go
first okay you know when one of the
benefits of this long presidential
campaign is you get to see in real time
what kind of decisions the different
candidates would make whose side they're
on and what the consequences are of
those choices President Obama has
consistently made the right decisions
for American workers and American
families he rescued the auto industry he
cracked down on unfair trade practices
by China he took aggressive action to
help responsible homeowners refinance he
cracked down in excessive payments to
banks and use that money to invest in
making college affordable he passed a
historic health care reform bill to
bring down health care costs and
substantially reduced the number of
Americans who don't have health
insurance and he's fought for the DREAM
Act which would make it possible for
young Americans who got to this country
through no fault of their own to have a
path to citizenship if they work hard in
school or serve the country in some
other way on the contrary Mitt Romney
said he wanted to let Detroit go
bankrupt he took China's side when the
US was in a trade dispute over tires and
earlier in the bush administration over
steel and he said we should let the
housing market hit bottom Mitt Romney is
a PO he said he would let the
president's tax credit for higher
education expire and when students asked
him how they should deal with mortgage
interest with with tuition debt he said
go take a loan from your parents and he
said that immigrants should self-deport
so going forward we need a president
who's going to make the tough calls
right and who understands that economic
prosperity is built around a strong
middle class okay thank you very much
chef and you stuck to two minutes even
though I didn't warn you beforehand that
was my ideal time so thanks a lot Glenn
last word of yours I had a statement but
I did want to reply briefly to the
questions a panel raised two Mike's
first on on narratives Romney has a
classic revenue neutral tax reform
narrative and the numbers quite easily
add up in that
he has a plan to and that would raise
eighteen nineteen percent of GDP he has
a plan to reduce spending to twenty
percent of GDP so I think those
narratives hang together on human
capital it's about education and
training but it is also about tax and
spending the fiscal policy path we are
on is ever increasing marginal tax rates
which will discourage human capital
investment but what I would say to you
is is this there's really no answer from
the President and governor romney aston
this as to what policies he's proposing
would increase growth and living
standards i ask that question again
tonight and it's mathematically
impossible for the president who is very
specific it's called a budget which we
can all look at it is mathematically
impossible to fund the spending in the
president's budget with the tax
increases the president suggests from an
economic perspective this election is
really about a few fundamental questions
the first is how can we best promote
economic growth and employment governor
romney believes that's through a series
of structural barriers being torn down
in fiscal pulse in regulatory policy
better trade policy and education and in
training to enable the private sector to
succeed second big question is what
should the size of government be this
country can have a strong defense it can
have a strong safety net it can have
strong education and keep modest tax
burden and growth what it cannot have is
the very large and exploding welfare
state that is currently on offer unless
it is willing to cut its composition of
spending that is forget about defending
the country or forget about education or
having much higher tax burdens on all
Americans that's math okay go on you
minute third third question what should
the scope of government be regulations
should be balancing limits with safety
and soundness with individual freedom
and growth but returning to my opening
comments I think we need a president who
has grasped focus in action of what's
going on in the economy and that's Mitt
Romney
okay thank you both very very much i
would like to also really thank our
wonderful faculty commentators Mike
Sharon Joe and above all our presenters
it is very easy to tut tut at our TV
screens or in the audience it's very
hard to stand on the podium and make
remarks especially when you have to be
careful not to get in trouble with the
campaign you are representing so I
really appreciate it and I would also
say especially the president Bollinger
where else could you hear a debate about
this truly consequential election where
my personal favorite line from this
conversation was follow the footnotes
and search your memories to remember who
it was who said that so thank you
everyone it was terrific
you